كنت أقرأ أخباري اليومية على
الإنترنت عندما لفت انتباهي عنوان رئيسي
صادم لم أكن أعتقد أنه قد يحدث أو
حتى من الممكن حدوثه ،
ومن المتوقع أن تفلس إحدى أكبر الدول المصدرة للنفط
في غضون خمس سنوات وفقًا
لتقرير صندوق النقد الدولي في هذه المرحلة  أدرك
مدى هشاشة الاقتصاد القائم على النفط
وكيف يمكن أن تنهار جميع مزاعم الرخاء
بمجرد نفاد النفط من الحكومة
والمنح المناسبة للأشخاص الذين
أجريت حديثًا معهم مؤخرًا مع زميل
لي حول الوضع الحالي
لبلدنا في  في نهاية حديثنا ، أخبرني ،
هيا ، نحن دولة غنية ، ولدينا
الكثير من النفط والاحتياطيات الهائلة ،
وسرعان ما سنزدهر ونزدهر ، لقد
فكرت قليلاً في هذا الأمر وحقيقة
أن هذه العقلية منتشرة على نطاق واسع في
جميع أنحاء بلدنا  بدأنا في
التساؤل عما إذا كانت الأرض التي
نعيش عليها مليئة بالنفط والموارد الطبيعية ،
فهذا يعني أننا أغنياء
وكيف يمكن أن يضمن هذا أن مجتمعنا
سوف يزدهر يومًا ما وشعبنا  سوف
يكون ople سعيدًا ويتمتع برفاهية عامة إيجابية
، قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ديفيد كاميرون ذات مرة إن
الحياة أكثر من المال
، وقد حان الوقت لنركز ليس فقط
على gdb ولكن على الرفاهية العامة gwb حتى
لو كان لدى البلد الكثير  من المال
والكثير من عائدات النفط التي
نريدها ، ولكن حتى لو كان لدينا هذا لا
يعني أن لدينا اقتصادًا مستقرًا ومستدامًا
وأن شعبنا يشترك في
رفاهية عامة إيجابية ، كل الآن
مؤشرات بلدنا تنخفض
ليس فقط  على نطاق نمو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي لدينا
ولكن الأهم من ذلك على نطاق
حالة الرفاهية العامة لدينا ،
وأعتقد أن هذا يعود إلى عامل رئيسي واحد فقط
أسميه اللعنة
وهو النفط إغراء
أرقام النفط والحصول على  أصبح المال السهل
من الحكومة هو الثقافة السائدة
التي تم تحجرها في
رأس شعبنا حتى بدأوا
يعتقدون أن النفط هو ما
سيجعل البلاد تنمو وتزدهر ولكن
الحقيقة أنها لم تكن كذلك  لا تفعل ذلك
في المستقبل ، فما الذي
يمكن أن يساعدنا في بناء اقتصاد عظيم
يمكنه الصمود بغض النظر عما يحدث في
تغيرات الأرانب هذه والاتجاهات
حول العالم جيدًا ، أول شيء يمكنني
إخبارك به هو اتباع هذه الخطوة من أجل
دائرة التوريد احكم علي نعم من كان
يتوقع ذلك نعم بعض الناس أصيبوا
بالرعب عندما سمعوا الخطاب
بمن فيهم أنا نعم اعتقد أن
النفط هو ما سيجعل البلد ينمو
ويزدهر ومصيرنا مرتبط
بمن
يطعمنا وإذا اختفوا  كلنا محكوم عليه بالفشل
ولكن الحقيقة هي
أن هذا النمو لا يمكن أن يأتي أبدًا من
النفط ويجب أن يعتمد نمونا
على عقلية المشاركة والنمو بطريقة
تجعل الناس سعداء لذلك كان بعض
الناس مرعوبين مثلي.  عندما يسمعون
الخطاب وهم يفكرون في أنهم سوف يقودوننا هؤلاء
الأشخاص يوميًا إلى
الازدهار ، لكن الحقيقة هي أن
الأشخاص هم الذين يمكنهم أن يجعلونا ننمو ونحتاج إلى
أشخاص لديهم أفكار ورأس مال بدلاً من
إطعام شخصهم.  يجب أن تساعدهم الحكومة في
تعلم كيفية صيد
أسماكهم ، والشيء الوحيد الذي نحتاجه الآن
هو المفهوم الذي يسمى رأسمالية المخاطرة
الأشخاص الذين لديهم أفكار ورأس مال
لأن التعاون بين
شبابنا النشطين الذين لديهم
أفكار رائعة ورجال الأعمال أو VCS  من هم
على استعداد للاستثمار في هذه الأفكار
سيخلقون بيئة أعمال غير
عادية ستخلق بيئة أعمال غير عادية
يمكن أن تساعدنا على
النمو والازدهار ألبرت أينشتاين قال ذات مرة
إن كل ما هو ذي قيمة في
المجتمع البشري يعتمد على الفرصة
الممنوحة للفرد لذلك حان الوقت نحن
توقف عن التفكير
وحساب عدد براميل النفط التي
سنصدرها وابدأ في التفكير وإحصاء
عدد الخريجين المؤهلين الذين يمكن
أن يكون نهجنا للازدهار
قائمًا على عقلية حيث يجب على كل فرد
في المجتمع المشاركة في
نمو بلده وترك  تتبع
وراءه أن الجيل الثاني
سيكون مصدر إلهام وفخور بالشكر ذ  أنت